Transcriber: Leen AlAli
المدقّق: gaith Takrity
السلام عليكم، كيف الحال؟
I`ll be speaking in Arabic first
then I`ll try to translate it
.to short sentences in English
so we`re all on the same page
.okay, I hope that is fine
أتكلم عن مخاوف الناس من الشهرة،
ولماذا هناك  الكثير من الناس
لا تريد أن تكون صانعة محتوى؟
لكن بنهاية الحديث ستكتشفون أن هذه المخاوف
يمكن أن تمنع الناس من أن تقوم بأي شيء.
Now of course
I`m talking about content creation
and why people are reluctant
? to create a content
but maybe by the end
,of this video you`ll realize
these are the reasons why people
.are reluctant to create anything
.Okay
?So who am I to talk about these fears
,I am Maitha Myth Journey
and I was able to convince
half a million followers to follow me
.through a year and a half
من أنا لأتكلم عن هذه المخاوف؟
لأني مررت بهذه المخاوف.
خلال سنة و نصف الحمد للّه
قدرت أجمّع أكثر من نصف مليون متابع
واستطعت أن أقنع نصف مليون شخص
أن يكون صديقي و رفيقي... فأهلاً.
حسناً.
دعيت  مرة إلى منتدى الإتصال الحكومي.
I was once invited
.to a governmental summit
and they invited
.a lot of content creatives
دعوا الكثير من صنّاع المحتوى،
و تصورنا سوياً.
لكن! هل تلاحظون شيءً غريباً في الصورة؟
Do you notice anything
?weird in the picture
(The audience is answering)
(You`re the only girl)
(You`re the shortest)
(Laughters)
I`m the shortest but this shouldn`t
come as a surprise... (Laughter)
Of course, someone said
.I`m the only girl
صحيح، قال أحدهم أنا البنت الوحيدة،
و هذا الشيء لم يدعنب فقط مستغربة،
لكنه جعل الكثير من الناس يستغربون.
لذلك شاركت في الستوري
لماذا لا يريد البنات
أن يكونوا صانعات محتوى؟
Why are girls reluctant
?to create content
,I asked this question on my story
and then I received a lot of
,answers from girls and guys
and people who doesn`t
.want even to create content
but they`re reluctant
.to create anything
so I tried to collect all these fears
.which I faced in my beginnings
.But I forgot along the way
And I`ll tell you now my
.perspectives on those fears
سأقول لكم ما هي تجربتي مع هذه
المخاوف و كيف استطعت أن أتخطاها.
.Okay
أول خوف هو التعليقات السلبية.
Maybe the first thing will get to
,your mind is negative comments
and how can we deal with
.negative comments
,The thing is
Imagine that you got a negative comment
.from a random person on the internet
تخيلوا لو انكم حصلتوا
على تعليق سلبي من شخص على النت،
هذا الشيء بأثّر.. لاأقول لا..
ولا أقول كونوا أقوياء..
No, we`re humans and we get
? affected by these things, right
لكن سأسألكم سؤالاً،
Would you take an advice
?from this person
(The audience is answering)
(Yes) , (No)
Would You take an advice from a
?random person on the internet
who thought that you look
?ugly for some reason
(The audience is answering)
(No)
Of course, of course you wouldn`t
.Of course you wouldn`t
And this question
.had the effect of magic on me
Every time someone
,commented something irrelevant
,Maybe on my looks
,maybe on the way I talk
.I get affected, but then I ask myself
Would I listen to an advice
? from this perso
And suddenly he
.becomes a nobody, suddenly
This advice I heard from
.a content creator and it`s like golden
So I repeat it to everyone asking me
.about the negative comments
.Okay
.And the other thing
الشيء الثاني.
The other thing that shouldn`t
.come as a surprise as well
هو الأشياء التي تخاف أن تسمعها،
أنت سمعتها بالفعل.
Things you`re too afraid
,to hear from people
.You`ve heard it already
?Where
.In your head
In your head, exactly, anxiety
?What happens with creative people
.We`re so hard on ourselves
الذي يحدث مع  الأشخاص المبدعين هو
أننا ننتقض أنفسنا كثيراً،
نحن نرى أصغر الأخطاء
التي نقوم بها و نكبرها بعيوننا.
فنخاف من أن نسمع نفس الكلام من الناس.
.But the reality is different
We are harder on ourselves than
,anyone else can be hard on us
so, whatever you said to
yourself is a hundred time worse
.than what you will hear, eventually
So, I mean like... the worst
,has already happened now
?so, maybe you get to this, right
.Okay
يعني أنكم سمعتم الكلام الذي تخافون
من أن تسمعونه من أنفسكم،
فما من شيء تخافون منه.
أومن الممكن هذه فلسفتي السوداء.
.then
الشيء الثاني هو الخصوصية.
.The second thing
People are really afraid to put
.themselves on the internet for privacy
See... as an Arabic people
.we are very protective on our privacy
We don`t like people knowing
,us in the street and stuff
.and I get it
.but the thing is
The thing about privacy is
.your audience is your mirror
?How, how, how is that relevant
ما علاقة أن جمهوري هو مرآتي بالخصوصية؟
إذاا أنت تضع فضائح الناس كمحتوى.
.as a content
إذا أنت تستغل فضائح الناس كمحتوى.
إذا أنت تستغل الأخبار السيئة كمحتوى.
.Of course Karma will hunt you
لكن إذا تضعي مثلاً أفكار للناس،
إذا تضعي إبداعك للناس،
إذا تشارك الناس بأسئلة
فالناس بفاجئونك بأنهم بيبدعون معك،
بأنهم بفكرون معك، لذلك جمهورك مرآتك.
إذا كان المحتوى الذي تضعه جيداً،
فليس هناك  داعي من أن تخاف
من أن ينقلب  جمهورك عليك.
If you put scandals and you
.shame people for content
Of course, your audience will
,come back and hunt you
but if you put out your ideas
if you provoke your audience`s creativity
They`ll be creative with you
and they`ll share even more ideas with you
.That`s why your audience is your mirror
(Applause)
Thank you
,And again, this thing about privacy
?we all should be like... cautious right
but this is the thing why I always go by
If you`re too cautious, don`t walk
because there is always
.a possibility that you will fall
?Right
.I mean be cautious but not too cautious
.Okay. And then
we have this thing and I heard
a lot of people saying it in the beginning
society
Why are you so afraid to put
? yourself out there
society
But what do we mean by this
word ? What do you mean by
المجتمع ؟
لماذا تخاف من أنك انت تضع نفسك
وتتكلم عن نفسك؟
المجتمع.
ماذا تقصد بالمجتمع؟
أولاً.
أولاً. نحن عندما نتكلم عن المجتمع
نحن نتكلم عن خبرة هي غير خبرتنا.
دعوني أقول مثلاً.
أنه هناك بنت تريد أن تكون صانعة محتوى
أو شخص يريد أن يكون صانع محتوى.
فبماذا من الممكن أن يفكر أول شي؟
ممكن يفكر بالناس الذين
.got cancelled
صحيح أم لل؟
أولما يأتي لبالنا نحن.
.We`re human we love drama
We always think about the
.worst case that I would face
دائماً نفكر بالأشخاص
الذين... got cancelled
...But the thing is
there experience is not yours
.and you are not them
Their content is
.different than yours
لماذا تقيسون أنفسكم بنفس المقياس؟
(Applause)
شكراً... هههههه
...Another
Another like weird thing that
,always comes to me
like when people say
.society makes us and society
You know like, who is the
? society if you think about it
You are a society
You`re a big part of it
,Because in a way
?you choose your people, right
You choose your circles everywhere
In the schools you choose your circles
even in family gatherers
you choose who you sit with
We don`t always like, okay right
we say hi to everyone
but then you go with your cousins that
you were feeling more comfortable with
So in the end, you are a society
If you are doing something
that you are not convinced of
of course people will be mad
But you are doing something
that you will cheer people for doing
people will cheer for you
نحن المجتمع
Okay
إذا نحن فعلنا شيء نحن
مقتنعين فيه ونحن نحبه.
و نعرف انه هو لايغضب أحد
و لا يأذي أحد.
نحصل على ناس يشجعونا عليه.
لكن إذا فعلنا شيء من البداية نحن
لسنا مقتنعين به و فقط من أجل الشهرة
Of course
هذا الشي ينقلب ضدنا بعدها.
ففي النهاية لا تقم بشيء
أنت لست مقتنع فيه مئة بالمئة.
Last thing is experience
I don`t have experience that`s why
I don`t want to put myself out there
I don`t want to start going on my path
I don`t have experience
so I don`t want to start on this skill
And my answer to this is
Don`t wait to start
Start so you get experienced
لا تنتظر أن تستعد لكي تبدأ.
ابدأ لكي تكون مستعداً.
شكراً .
(Applause)